some of the next keywords impossible
love for example it's a men's subject a
few short story in a sampradaya it's
also one of the main subject for you
another design of light it's hard to
love a new others right what it's it's
hard to love in life have you noticed I
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
don't know I mean that there's this part
of me and certainly this was very true
of me in the early 20s if you read mine
if you read the stories that focus in
the first decade of my career than
myself in the nineteen seventies it's
immensely romantic in both senses of the
word and it's the romance of distant
places and just the planets all very
colorful and exotic take very Jack Van C
and kind of stuff Jack Vance for a long
time has been my favorite science
fiction and fantasy writer but it's also
romantic in the sense of you know
44:11
and finding true love all of that some
of this is obviously a yearning of
myself when I was looking for as many
people do in their teens and 20s looking
looking for that one person looking for
the true love the impossibility of
finding it the whole existential
loneliness they are even on there with
someone sometimes where when not with
someone because we're all we're all
separate from each other we don't have
to let the Fate like via does we can we
can't psychically bond with someone we
have these crude instruments of words to
try to express our feelings and get
things across and worried about we're
going to say the wrong thing we're going
to lose the very thing that we most
desire and and you know it's it's all
difficult than just sex which makes it
even thousand times so one that was
material to be explored and I did try to
explore it in a number of stories of
which a song for Lyon is probably the
most successful but there was also
things like a second kind of loneliness
and this tower of ashes and for a single
yesterday and the lonely songs in Lehren
door and in the lost lands and on and on
and on it was it was a subject that I
spent a lot of time exploring and and
grappling with it's the subject be some
characters of some of Ice and Fire
to an extent yes yes but there's a lot
of other things going on it's alright
I read another book that I frequently
reread is Fitzgerald's The Great Gatsby
we were talking about romance before
that's one of the that was one of the
most romantic books I've ever read and I
read it at a formative error when I was
you know having my heart broken
frequently and and writing a lot of my
most romantic science fiction it's
interesting to get back to this issue of
romance those who raised early and when
I was in Spain a few years ago I had I
had dinner with a woman of Spanish
academic and a big fan of websites
returned and romances she had read a lot
of my stuff as people said I was a very
romantic writer and she should have
watched it to me at dinner saying what
do you talk about you're not a romantic
writer you know nobody ever lives
happily ever everybody knows what said
and it's always that I was defending I
would say well but that's a different
traditional romance I don't I'm a
romantic writer the tradition of like a
Great Gatsby in Romeo and Juliet and and
you know these these things don't
necessarily have happy endings they
aren't the most powerful romances the
unfulfilled romances the romances where
people go their separate ways and and
but they'll always have fairness right
like doesn't like that one of the films
I should here you know think of separate
at the end but they'll always have Paris
she basically said no you're wrong I
have to be happily ever after together
for it to be romance otherwise it's just
series I was seas of Canaries and
another one caking and then I saw this
must be a woman writing is and because
it really there was a yeah this insight
in these characters especially women and
it's very precise so I was just really
amazed to see that it was a man thank
you you know definitely am a man
don't have any ghostwriter no III don't
I don't but you know I do occasionally
consult with women know what I know a
lot of them but something you don't have
to solve as I said earlier in the
interview but I think the differences
between men and women are small compared
to the similarities but our common
humanity the things that we all go
through the search for as they say
custom Lanka is all this thing little
story I search for love and glory but
there are experiences that that I
haven't had and what I'm writing about
one of those I I tried to talk to people
who have had that experience you know
when I first had brand crippled by his
fall from the tower
I had one fan who was was paraplegic and
he and I exchanged a number of emails
about okay what what was it like to be
Beverly because I couldn't try to
imagine that but I don't actually know
that when I wrote the scene where salsa
has her first period this is an
experience that I've also never had but
I talked to a number of women's and what
was the like when you had your first
period was it scary was that nothing was
it painful was it tell me about it and I
got you know like 16 different stories
vary widely when people who have
actually been in combat and talk to
before the combat
that too varies widely that's sort of
interesting and of course I've read a
lot about that but but there are certain
experiences that only women have had a
cigar society and when I'm trying to
tackle them I try to consult with women
but I can definitely say that I am I am
a man but I'm glad you think I like
random women well I certainly try as I
try with all of these characters